the ripple effect from the pandemic
still remains
many people out of work for different
kind of work looking for different kind
of work including one cirque du soleil
performer
who is now a plumber christian casada
shares his story
and if he has any plans to eventually
return to the stage christian
well denise roman polyshock says after
23 years and over 6 500 performances
it's time to step back his career is now
completely changed
he works at ghetto air conditioning and
plumbing
this is my truck it's been almost a year
since roman polishuk has been on stage
but his talent as a performer is hard to
ignore when he is fixing broken pipes
i just try to do that and everything
inside and i'm trying to fix
the things he joined cirque du soleil 23
years ago and traveled the world
he's been recognized with some of the
highest awards in his field and has
countless stories of his career
this is the celebrities who i met his
life took a sudden turn when the
pandemic forced everything to close
when we was doing the show and after
next day we come to back to the work and
they told us
show us cancer for today and be like
what the point they say well the problem
is we have this
pandemic hit around the world so all the
shows been cancelled around the world
so they give us about what four days to
stand by so we're waiting every day
so it might be open but they say okay
show is canceled and
you have the guys all going home without
a job roman says a friend at this air
conditioning and plumbing company
reached out i feel good i'm working i'm
learning
something new in my life so it's good
for me
his experience on stage including his
participation in viva elvis
allows him to be more flexible at work
and spend time with family
i want to have like dinner with my
family i want to like my kids going to
the school
bring them to school take them back from
the school like like go with the park
because
when in this circus you you'll
come back home at 12 o'clock at night
amazing career
well roman tells us he still does what
he can to stay active but at 48 years
old
many of his priorities have changed
christian casadas 8 news now